Marvel Studios grabbed headlines with
his presentation of the MCU pays for
slate at SDCC 2019 and along with the
intriguing new titles came some enticing
cast announcements these are just some
of the actors set to make a big splash
in the MCU along with some clues as to
where you've seen them before at the
2019 San Diego comic-con Marvel Studios
revealed some details of its long
anticipated black widow standalone movie
including the confirmation that rising
English star Florence Pugh would portray
a character named Yelena Bulova who the
actress described as a sister figure to
Natasha Romanoff Pugh first appeared on
screen in the 2014 British film the
falling from there she moved on to the
romantic drama Lady Macbeth
which she followed with the role as
Cordelia in the 2018 TV movie version of
King Lear more recently she had roles in
Chris Pines 14th century Scottish epic
outlaw King and AMC's assassination
thriller miniseries The Little Drummer
girl Pugh is having a very good 2019
just before the announcement that she'd
co-star in Black Widow she played a
younger version of real-life WWE
wrestler page and the well-received
comedy fighting with my family she
followed that immediately with the lead
role in midsummer
the critical darling of a horror movie
about a weird Swedish cult and it's not
so innocuous solstice festival the
upcoming Black Widow movie will also
include a character named Rick Mason a
former shield contact of Natasha's and a
possible love interest landing that
pivotal role London born actor Ooty peg
Ben lay his Black Widow gig is the role
that will likely make him a household
name as up to now he's primarily been a
prolific actor on a variety of British
television series not widely known
outside the UK but we started his career
acting in plays that Ben Lai eventually
began to balance his stage work with TV
taking on parts in brick coms like
grown-ups FM and material girl along
with a couple of episodes of Doctor Who
he got his first major exposure
stateside on HBO's romantic drama
looking as Frank a guy with some
relationship problems Pegg Bentley found
his breakthrough role on Hulu's
harrowing emmy-winning adaptation of
Margaret Atwood's The Handmaid's Tale
he plays Luke Bank whole husband of June
prior to the dystopian revolution that
resulted in Gilead in December 2018
Marvel informed fans
a film about kungfu master and superhero
shang-chi he was on the way san diego
comic-con 2019 brought more news
including a full title of shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings and
confirmation that it would be Marvel's
first movie headlined by actors of Asian
descent among the lead cast rapper and
actress
aquafina the rural remains undisclosed
her meteoric rise in recent years makes
her inclusion in Marvel's exciting new
enterprise very noteworthy born under
the name nor alum Aquafina first gained
attention for her music her songs are
frequently funny and satirical and that
sense of humor led to supporting roles
in comedy movies and TV shows such as
sorority lady Christine in neighbours
too and a recurring role as a mean video
game store employee on future man hey um
you're still dating that like chemists
guy right the professor or dude wile no
I broke up a call Professor X now huh
that's funny aquafina broke out in a big
way in the summer of 2018 appearing in
two hit ensemble comedies and nearly
stealing them both ocean's 8 and crazy
rich Asians before you catch her in
shang-chi when it hits theaters in
February 2021 aquafina can be seen in
the lead role of indie drama d the
farewell and will soon appear in Jumanji
the next level the third SpongeBob
SquarePants movie and the live-action
remake of The Little Mermaid a scuttle
Chinese Canadian actor C movie U has
built up a solid acting resume appearing
on many television series filmed in the
great white north and extremely minor
roles from there though he moved up to a
recurring role on the Canadian crime
drama blood and water and the central
role of a strange son Jung on the hit
CBS sitcom Kim's convenience Leo made
his way into American television as
ex-cia guy firown' on NBC's short-lived
TV adaptation of taken and worked as a
stunt double on heroes reborn and
designated survivor in the spring of
2019 he guest starred on an episode of
fresh off the boat as a helpful type a
street vendor named Willy who helps out
broke lost main character Eddie
portraying shang chi and shang chi and
the legend of the ten ring smartly used
first starring role in a feature film
Marvel's phase four will include the
Eternals a story about alien immortal
sent to earth to protect humanity
joining an already star-studded cast as
Bryan
Thierry Henry who will portray Fastow's
back in 2016
Henry found his breakout role
world-weary late-blooming rapper alfred
miles AKA paperboy on donald glover
surreal FX drama d atlanta no he's kind
of funny he's hot right now you should
work with him as a manager just because
you just like the city's great it'll
make you more managing life henry earned
an Emmy nomination for his work but
that's not the only Awards attention
he's received before moving into
television and movies Henry putting some
time on Broadway he acted and sang as
part of the ensemble in the Book of
Mormon the musical by Trey Parker and
Matt Stone of South Park in 2018
he used part of his Atlanta hiatus to
return to the Great White Way starring
in the play lobby hero for which he
received a Tony Award nomination the
exposure from Atlanta and Broadway
helped Henry move into film and he's
landed supporting roles in many major
movies in 2018 Henry appeared in three
acclaimed films widows if Beale Street
could talk and spider-man into the
spider-verse in which he lent his voice
to the father of hero Miles Morales
Henry co-starred is detective Mike
Norris in the 2019 remake of child's
play he's also set to appear in Joker
Godzilla vs. Kong and a quiet place to a
lot of actors struggle for years to find
work in major Hollywood blockbusters
others get a little luck added to their
talent and get asked to join the cast of
save a potentially huge Marvel Studios
blockbuster with only a handful of
screen credits to their name the center
of such a Hollywood success story
actress Lauren read law cast as alien
superhuman Macari and Marvel's upcoming
the Eternals she'll play the first-ever
deaf hero in the MCU a former
stay-at-home mom and miss deaf america
ridd LOF got into acting when she landed
a part in if you could hear my own tune
a film about how deaf people perceive
music gridlock men appeared in the
fantastical wonderstruck an episode of
The CW's supernatural series legacies
and an installment of NBC's medical
drama Margo her most prominent role
before the Eternals however was
portraying hilltop survivor Connie
during the ninth season of The Walking
Dead away from TV rid Laverne to Tony
Award nomination for her work and a
revival of children of a lesser God at
the 2019 San Diego comic-con
Marvel announced that a reboot to blade
was on the way
for its imminent sleights of Marvel
Cinematic Universe face for movies but
as part of the distant base 5 marsala
alley one of the most acclaimed actors
of his generation will be playing the
titular vampire hunter just days before
his introduction as the new blade Ally
received an Emmy Award nomination for
Outstanding Lead Actor in a limited
series or movie for his work as a
haunted Louisiana crime investigator on
HBO's True detective and in February
2009 teen Ally won an Academy Award for
Best Supporting Actor for green book in
which he portrayed real-life pns dr.
Donald Shirley opposite his driver
bodyguard Tony played by Viggo Mortensen
even press several people with you our
innate ability to handle trouble
and that is why I called and inquired
about your availability that made for
Ally's second Oscar in just three years
the first one in 2017 for his work in
moonlight Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige reported that spinning Oscar gold
into comic book vampire adventures was
actually Ali's idea which just makes us
even more excited to see what he does
with the role check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you